let's say now we want to throw a  beautiful king bed into our fancy  shipping container well the king bed is  2.16  long so if you want to orientate the  king bed in the most logical position on  the shorter side of that actual shipping  container you can't you're not going to  be able to fit a king bed so that means  you have to orientate it the opposite  way and only have 8.5 centimeters either  side of your bed which means you can't  walk past the side of your bed to get in  you have to climb in from the back of  the bed every single time  if you want to see the full video and  all things architecture related make  sure you hit that subscribe button